come on in here boys how's it going this  is the great wind stuff on E  are you yeah that's Blake Shelton giving  his girlfriend Gwen Stefani quite a  sweet introduction on monday's episode  of The Voice where the singer continued  her role as a mentor for her beau's team  the duo definitely flirted on camera  last week but this week they kicked it  up a notch like one for an expert to  help you guys  good call so he called me a country  music yeah expert I loved working  outside of mine yeah also she's hot  wait what was that Blake also she's hot  we agree and we think the feeling is  mutual  the couple's romance is just as adorable  off screen when shared this video to  snapchat on Monday taking a nature walk  with her man and her youngest son Apollo